la cinemática es la geometría del
movimiento para simplificar el
movimiento del dedo índice los tres
huesos del dedo son modelados por
cilindros estrechos las dos
articulaciones se modelan como pequeñas
esferas de punto 1 centímetros de
diámetro que rotan desde el centro al
dedo lo que lo matemos al plano
cartesiano muy bien entonces el dibujo
del que estamos hablando es este aquí
tenemos digamos el dedo estirado que
tiene ciertas longitudes que ahorita
tenemos pero cada uno de estos huesos
está modelado por un cilindro que ya
está visto digamos en el plano
cartesiano que hay proyectado ahí y
entre cada hueso hay una articulación de
punto 1 centímetros de diámetro muy bien
y está y esta articulación puede rotar a
partir de su centro dice el primer hueso
tiene una longitud de 2.4 centímetros y
aquí está marcado el hueso de enmedio
tiene dos tercios la longitud del
primero si pensamos en una tercera parte
de 2.4 es dividir 2.4 entre 3 y eso
0.8 así que si este mide dos tercios en
realidad mide 1.6 y finalmente nos dicen
que y el hueso superior tiene un tercio
la longitud del primero que habíamos
dicho que era 0.8 verdad ahora el centro
de la yema del dedo se encuentra en 0 5
cuando el puño está abierto entonces no
se puede jugar ahorita con tu con tu
mano verlo y si lo estiras estamos
pensando que el puño está abierto y en
el punto x que cuando está cerrado
entonces cierra tu puño de hecho yo lo
estoy haciendo en este momento y puedo
ver más o menos que la forma de mi dedo
índice es esta que se muestra aquí abajo
aunque es esta de aquí ahora cuál es la
coordenada x en x
nos están preguntando cuál es la primera
coordenada de la yema después de doblar
lo que de hecho aquí se puede más o
menos ver entonces voy a hacer un dibujo
para que podamos ver esto mucho más
grande
digamos que aquí tenemos nuestro primer
hueso ya ha doblado quizás debería
hacerlo todo de un solo trazo
ok digamos que aquí tenemos
nuestro primer dedo ok entonces este es
el hueso
este es el hueso pero terminando el
hueso existe esta articulación verdad
que de hecho lo voy a hacer como muy
grande pero esencialmente es una
esférica y que en el plano lo podemos
ver como como un círculo
ahí tienen ustedes por supuesto esto no
está hecho a escala pero es para que
quede muy clara la idea muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos esta articulación
que si lo pensamos tiene bueno sabemos
que de diámetro tiene el punto 1
centímetros de largo verdad entonces si
pensamos en su radio en realidad tiene
un radio de 0.05 centímetros muy bien
ahora bien cuál es la longitud de este
segmento si este segmento es en realidad
el primer hueso esto mide 2.4
centímetros muy bien vamos a ver qué
ocurre después con el siguiente dedo
aquí de hecho está marcado que este
ángulo es de 45 grados hay que tenerlo
muy en mente sale entonces este dedo más
bien este hueso perdón
más o menos se ve de esta forma y dice
que mide dos terceras partes de 2.4 que
más o menos podemos decir que es esto y
esto tiene una longitud de 1.6 muy bien
y nuevamente viene al final de este dedo
una articulación que lo vemos como una
esférica verdad y tenemos que esta
esfera rota desde el centro entonces
si pensamos en la longitud de todo este
segmento digamos que es el hueso más un
punto 0 5 y otro punto 0 5 cada uno de
los radios respectivos de las
articulaciones en realidad aquí tenemos
que la longitud de este segmento
completito digamos pensándolo
desde el centro de la articulación hasta
el otro centro de la articulación en
realidad hay que sumar sumarle punto 1
verdad hay que sumarle punto 1 porque es
sumar dos veces puntos 0 5 y esto nos da
y 1.7 muy bien ahora bien tenemos
nuestro último huesito que va desde aquí
y dice que va en un ángulo recto
va desde aquí
más o menos de esta forma
y esto me de 0.8 ok entonces esto mide
0.8 0.8 y que en realidad podemos
sumarle este digamos esta longitud
verdad que es la distancia del hueso
digamos al centro de la articulación que
en realidad es sumarle 0.05 y nos da y
nos da punto 85
0.85 espero no hacer mucho relajo y
encimar todo a la larga entonces la
pregunta es este este punto tienen
ciertas coordenadas x
nos interesa ver cuál es la distancia x
es decir cuál es la distancia podemos
pensarlo de esta forma del del eje
al punto en donde se encuentra la yema
del dedo muy bien entonces para ver eso
vamos a necesitar utilizar triángulos
verdad por ejemplo si quisiéramos ver la
posición de este punto de aquí de este
punto de aquí podríamos utilizar
trigonometría de la siguiente forma
trazamos una recta que vaya de forma
vertical y que por lo tanto con esta con
este segmento que corresponde al hueso
hacia un ángulo de 90 grados además
sabemos que este ángulo de aquí es de 45
grados entonces para saber cuál es la
coordenada x de este punto donde se
encuentra el centro de la articulación
podríamos pensar en 2.4 o más bien este
más bien sería 2.45 verdad en realidad
tenemos todo esto todo esta longitud y
quizás dejo hacerlo un poco mejor
de esta longitud o todo este segmento en
realidad es 2.4 y le sumamos un radio
que es 0.05 y esto es 2.45 entonces ya
toda esta longitud le restamos lo que
mide digamos este este segmento que es
de donde va desde el pie de esta altura
digamos hasta el centro de esta esfera
si le restamos esta distancia podríamos
encontrar la coordenada de este punto la
coordenada x ahora bien este es un
problema de trigonometría porque yo
tengo un ángulo y también conozco esta
hipotenusa verdad de hecho me de 1.7 así
que qué función trigonométricas me
relaciona un ángulo con la hipotenusa y
el cateto adyacente
pues eso es justamente el coseno del
ángulo verdad entonces por un lado
tenemos que el coseno de 45 grados
coseno de 45 grados es igual al cateto
adyacente voy a llamarle
de hecho lo va a marcar con rojo para
que se vean más claro de qué estamos
hablando y el coseno de 45 grados es el
cateto adyacente el déjenme ponerlo con
otro color es el cateto adyacente entre
la hipotenusa que es 1.7 en otras
palabras estamos diciendo que esta
longitud que nuestro valor a es igual a
1.7 1.7 por el coseno de 45 grados por
el coseno de 45 grados así que si nos
preguntamos cuál es la coordenada de
este la coordenada x de este punto en
realidad es
toda esta longitud que es 2.45 2.45
menos lo que vale a que en este caso es
1.7 coseno de 45 grados muy bien y
tenemos una coordenada ya que en
realidad pues quizás no sea necesario ya
veremos si lo vamos
pero no ahora bien si nosotros ya
tenemos cuánto vale esta longitud y
nosotros queremos saber cuál es la
posición o la coordenada x de este punto
que este es nuestro punto equis y este
de aquí entonces podríamos utilizar la
misma técnica poniendo un triángulo de
esta forma muy bien
de esta forma ok o bien vamos a verlo de
forma equivalente qué tal si ponemos un
triángulo así
tenemos esta base ponemos un lado
paralelo al superior
y entonces qué es lo que tenemos aquí
tenemos un ángulo de 90 grados este
ángulo de aquí es de 90 grados y lo que
podemos ver es que está recta que
corresponde al hueso de enmedio es es
transversal a dos paralelas y por lo
tanto por los ya sabemos que los lados
bueno este ángulo sería igual a este
otro ángulo verdad
muy bien entonces eso es porque esta
recta es transversal a dos paralelas y
si este mide 45 y este 90 este tiene que
medir 45 para que así tengamos que los
tres ángulos sumen 180 grados muy bien y
entonces podemos conocer ahora esta
longitud verdad porque nuevamente
tendremos que el coseno de 45 grados
coseno de 45 grados será igual al cateto
adyacente que es justo el que queremos
conocer vamos a llamarle x entre la
longitud de la hipotenusa que la
longitud de la hipotenusa es punto 85
verdad es justamente el hueso más el
radio de la articulación entonces es
0.85 o en otros términos x que es el
lado que nos interesa es igual este es
este es nuestro lado x verdad entonces x
será igual
0.85 0.85 por el coseno de 45 grados por
el coseno de 45 grados entonces cuál
será la coordenada aquí pues nuestra
coordenada será igual a lo que media
este lado que era dijimos que era 2.45
menos 1.7 por el coseno de 45 grados y
ahora hay que restarle esta longitud x
verdad esta longitud de x es la que hay
que restarle y esto era 0.85 coseno de
45 grados y si factor izamos bueno aquí
tenemos una coordenada de verdad que no
nos interesa no nos interesa porque sólo
nos preguntaron la coordenada x así que
si uno quiere factorizar en realidad uno
puede concluir que esta longitud es 2.45
menos 1.7 más punto 85 de esos son
punto 55 por el coseno de 45 grados y no
importa quién sea la coordenada y es
verdad así que ahí lo tienen esa es la
coordenada x y no sabemos la coordenada
y pero sólo nos pidieron la primera de
ellas